how do you do that you don't have any
positive role model
around you i can't fix my car yeah or i
can't defend myself yeah in a combat
scenario in the streets so what are you
gonna do okay this is real simple go do
things
go do things
lift start lifting weights
learn how to deadlift learn how to squat
learn some jiu-jitsu i recommend that
probably could have guessed that one
yeah i don't know how to react when
people like get in my face i said do you
train jiu-jitsu no start training
jiu-jitsu start building things rewire
things what i'm saying is it's not
impossible yeah it's not impossible to
do and it'll take you more time but
you're learning how to do it and that
gives you it gives you
the self-reliance right hey i can fix my
electrical outlet if i need to
if you have time
do it yourself yeah and don't be
embarrassed about it be like hey i'm
rewiring my kitchen i have no idea what
i'm doing give me this book yeah what do
i need to get oh give me some tools